hi everyone I'm Nugent Chung and I'm
your class of 2009 treasurer and it's my
pleasure to introduce our class a
speaker for today in the biography
section of his book little green men
Christopher Buckley wrote that he has
been an advisor to every single US
president since William Howard Taft a
remarkable achievement since he was born
in 1952 22 years after president has
death luckily nowadays everything and
everyone is googleable so I was able to
find the real biographical information
on our speaker for one before I speaker
matriculated at Yale he spent the year
hopping from train to train around the
world something that sounds just a
little bit more exciting and interesting
that investment banking and consulting
his adventures on the train resulted in
his first book and and is having the
distinction of being one of the few
members of his yell class of 1975 to
sport a tattoo while at Yale he majored
in the Yale Daily News and minor in
English by age 24 he was managing editor
of the Esquire magazine by 29 he was a
chief speechwriter to Vice President
George HW Bush in which job he thought
that his features will change the course
of history then 48 hours later he
realized and i called it doesn't matter
what the vice president says
his latest novel losing mom and pop a
memoir with parents William F Buckley Jr
class of nineteen fifty and Patricia
Taylor Buckley was brilliantly arranged
by our speaker to reach number six on
the new york times bestsellers list
ranking just in time for today's speech
our speaker is also a founding editor of
the Forbes FYI magazine has written over
60 comic essays in The New Yorker and is
a frequent contributor to both the New
York Times and The Daily Beast com were
his controversial endorsement of
President Obama ran last October when
asked by the ydn to preview his address
our speaker stated i would probably in
the first paragraph explain how to solve
the financial crisis in the second
paragraph I would I think I would deal
swiftly with how to achieve peace in the
Middle East and in the third paragraph i
would probably talk about how to get a
job at starbucks i think the business
and the political world will be
listening intently for the answers to
the first two problems we graduates
however really look forward to getting
the insights on the starbucks
opportunity please join me in welcoming
the 2009 class day speaker mr.
Christopher Buckley
thank you you Jen president did I screw
that up yeah well that didn't take long
did it president Levin Dean Miller
provost Sal of a masters and deans of
the residential colleges my new BFF
master penny Lauren's news and go je
members of the graduating class I am
tickled and a bit nervous to find myself
up here as Mark Twain once said facing a
large intimidating audience homers dead
Shakespeare's dead and i myself am not
feeling it all well I'm especially glad
to find myself here today since it gives
me the opportunity to make a long
overdue apology on this day this very
day over 30 years ago I stood here in
this spot in the capacity of class
historian that's a great hat my my
speech concluded by quoting a bit of
graffiti that I had found it in the
men's room of the cross campus library
or they
vast library as it's now called you
don't have graffiti anymore it's two
grand a a bathroom stall is I yes I know
a strange place to find inspiration but
it seemed perfectly to sum up the
essence of the class of 1975 so I felt I
had no choice but to quote it verbatim
the problem was that its punchline
contained a certain four-letter word
beginning with the letter that generally
designates a failing grade here it is in
cleaned-up version God didn't create the
world in seven days he bleeped off for
six days and pulled an all-nighter
thank you well well there with there was
this gasp the sound of all the oxygen in
old campus being sucked into eight
thousand lungs the owner of one of those
lungs was my dear old dad class of
nineteen fifty the next day he presented
me with my graduation present a
typewriter for of whose keys had been
removed so I'd like to start off today
thirty-four years later by formally
apologizing to God to country and to
Yale
for my appalling lapse of looks at
veritas on that otherwise lovely May Day
or as we say in Washington my prior
statement is inoperative this afternoon
you will hear only the refined and lofty
sentiments typical of a Yale English
major whether I have anything like
wisdom to impart is another matter as a
witty movie critic wrote about a non
masterpiece that he had just watched it
is like a river runs through it only
there is no River and nothing is running
through it apart from the profane
graffiti the the story that to me best
sums up my time here took place on the
eve of the Harvard game in 1975 the day
before Generalissimo franken's Francisco
Franco the longtime dictator of Spain
had finally died after an interminable
illness some people have terminal
illnesses Franco had an interminable
illness seizing the moment three plucky
yay Lee's got a ladder and a bucket of
paint and roller brush and climbed up on
top of the building that's now the
Barnes & Noble bookstore on Broadway
they painted over a huge billboard in
giant letters November 20 Franco
November 21st Harvard
on reaching the sidewalk they were
accosted by the New Haven Police they
radula frisked and thrown up against the
wall at which point the arresting
officer said okay which one of you guys
is Franco to me that story contains the
whole old relationship of Yale to New
Haven and eight words today chief parati
always get on the good side of the cops
today chief parati would send out an
email saying consistent with federal
reporting requirements I write to inform
you of an incident yesterday involving a
billboard looking back on it looking
back on it I think the 70s were a bit
like the present era as with today there
was a recession going on and that one
somewhat like this one had been partly
caused by the previous generations best
and brightest getting the country
involved in a civil war overseas that
one was in Southeast Asia today's best
and brightest thankfully did not repeat
that mistake they were smarter than that
they got us into civil wars in the
Middle East it seems odd that the phrase
best and brightest should be such a
pejorative term so today I will not
insult you by calling you the best and
the brightest of your generation instead
I will call you darned smart and really
good-looking
strange to to consider that the three
people most responsible for the Iraq war
that is the President the Secretary of
Defense and head of the occupation
Authority went respectively to Yale
Princeton and Yale you'd expect to foul
up with that magnitude from Princeton
but Yale but then it occurred to me that
the President and occupation Authority
had had gone on to graduate study at
Harvard which explains everything oddly
they all three of them had one thing in
common they all went to end over
what lesson do we draw from this it's
pretty obvious no one who went to end
over must be allowed anywhere near u.s.
foreign policy now a graduation speaker
is supposed to urge you to save the
world as Twain said yes I quote Twain a
lot he's funny or dead than I am alive
as he put it to be good is noble but to
show others how to be good is nobler and
no trouble I could stand here and urge
you all to party on but I take my role
as classed a speaker seriously so I too
will urge you to save the world it could
use some saving poor old world this
hasn't been the most excellent of
millenniums
you entered your teens just around the
time of 911 and now you're entering the
job market to use a somewhat ironic term
for it during the job market during the
Great Recession I can hear you thinking
thank you prior generations thank you so
much as a french philosopher put it the
trouble with our times is that the
future isn't what it used to be being
French he probably went on strike after
saying that what is it with the future
anyway why is it so uncooperative why
can't it just get with the program when
I was here when I was a student here we
were preoccupied with the threat of
nuclear war with the Soviet Union China
was still a commie dictatorship
computers were something only those
total loser computer science majors
cared about and the idea of an
african-american u.s. president was
about as plausible as Ronald Reagan as
president today we no longer worry about
nuclear war with the Soviet Union which
frees us up to worry about one of
pakistan's 100 nuclear weapons arriving
in new york harbor aboard a
containership I never thought I'd be
looking back on the cold war with
nostalgia
life used to imitate John Locke ra
novels now it imitates Tom Clancy novels
as an English major I'm not sure this
represents progress
as for China it's no longer a commie
dictatorship its rulers just don't think
people should be able to access Google
today americans love China in fact we're
indebted to China but perhaps most
amazing most cool of all America finally
elected its first african-american
president
a Harvard man but remember it might not
have happened if it hadn't been for a
Yale man George W Bush so the future is
hard to call if you're lucky and you all
look lucky to me in addition to being
darned smart and really good-looking if
you're lucky your futures will be hard
to predict I say lucky because I I think
one of the most exciting things about
life is its unpredictability as Dorothy
Parker put it what fresh hell is this
whatever it sort of climbs up on you
whatever you think lies in store out
there for you there's a pretty good
chance it's going to turn out
differently as the Yiddish proverb goes
want to make God laugh tell him your
plans today I would revise that to want
to make God laugh show him your 401k now
I don't know exactly how to advise you
here to be honest I'm still trying to
figure it all out myself they used to
screen late-night movies in LC 114 maybe
they still do almost every night and
those happy bygone days you could catch
an Ingmar Bergman movie for a buck what
better way to unwind after a long night
at the library than sitting in hard
upright wooden seats watching
incomprehensible black-and-white Swedish
art movies and every night you know it
always happened right at the climactic
moment when death was playing chess with
Max von Sydow and the eerie music was
swelling and you didn't have the
foggiest idea what the heck these
brooding Swedish persons were talking
about someone at the back of the room
would shout out what does it mean
your generation being more sophisticated
than mine came up with an all-purpose
answer to that pressing existential
question whatever we didn't have that
word in my day it was your generation
that came up with the whole concept of
whatever and on behalf of my generation
I want to say thank you it's just
brilliant and philosophically airtight
there is no proposition no argument
dogma a separation boast or claim that
can't be stopped dead in its tracks by
an american teenager with an iPod in his
or her ears saying whatever try it to be
or not to be whatever the only thing we
have to fear is fear itself whatever
mission accomplished
whatever but whatever life holds in
store for you remember the words of that
most quotable of American philosophers
Yogi Berra when I come to a fork in the
road I take it now your first fork is
right there on the other side of phelps
gate and my advice to you is to take it
fortunately College Street runs both
ways but at some point in your life's
journeys having taken some fork or other
you'll probably look up and see a large
red sign that says wrong way don't worry
about it just make sure your brakes work
because sometimes it's exciting going
the wrong way and it's always fun
watching the faces of the oncoming
drivers as the saying goes experience is
the name we give to our mistakes
Kierkegaard a sort of Swedish person
said life is best understood backwards
but must be lived forward to that I say
whatever may 2009 may not seem like a
terrific time to be starting out on
life's journey but take heart it might
be a better time than you think some of
you i'm guessing will not be going into
the training program at lehman brothers
or AIG or one of those best and
brightest Wall Street firms that came up
with such great ideas as credit default
swaps or collateralized debt obligations
but did you really want to model your
lives on a characters in Tom Wolfe
novels I always wanted to be Tom Wolfe
but I never wanted to be sure Minh McCoy
it was in English 25 as it was then
designated that I first came across the
line radix malorum st cupido toss I'll
translate for the benefit of the parents
no I know you went to college too money
is the root of all evil now being
Republican I of course do not believe
that but I do think Marilyn Monroe was
onto something when she said I don't
care about money I just want to be
wonderful remember Kierkegaard and
Marilyn Monroe that's that's that's you
try it remember that whatever happens
there are always two ways of looking at
it we we just had another one of those
anthrax scares at the post office in
Washington lately call me old-fashioned
but I remember a time when you were
actually thrilled to find some white
powder in an envelope
kidding John Major former Prime Minister
of Great Britain one day found himself
in a green room with Boris Yeltsin than
President of Russia they were about to
give a joint press conference major said
Boris if you had to describe the state
of Russia in one word what would you say
the Alton thought for a moment and said
good major said well what if you had two
words to describe the state of Russia
Yeltsin said not good
so this crummy economy that we've kindly
provided you with may have an upside you
may end up in a better place for it your
lives may be deeper and more enriched
but whatever else happens think of the
wonderful bonding you'll experience when
you move back in with your parents how
happy they all look and now a word to
the parents this is your day almost as
much as it is their day not really but I
just thought you'd like me to say that
but well done mom well done dad did you
ever think back in 1988 when you were
dandling them on your knees and being
spit up on that one day you'd be sitting
on uncomfortable chairs on old campus
tears welling in your eyes knowing that
you would written your last tuition
check to Yale University boola boola
or as they say over at the development
office mula mula and so my about to be
fellow alumni I wish you every success
as you and enter that never-ending
graduate school code life have
adventures make journeys make memories
make future yay Lee's say the cool lines
what do I mean by that well I was cold
for jury duty not long ago during the
preliminary part called wired ear which
you French majors know translates as
interminable process that makes you
regret registering to vote the judge was
asking us some questions about our
suitability to serve being red-blooded
Americans grateful for the sacrifices of
Valley Forge and the founders who left
as the Constitution and the Bill of
Rights we were naturally all doing our
best to weasel out of jury duty I saw my
opportunity when the judge asked us if
any of us knew anyone in law enforcement
I was married at the time to a CIA
officer I saw my chance but not wanting
to end up like poor scooter libby yale
class of 72 i raised my hand and said
Your Honor may I approach I'd seen this
on law and order
he looked at me and said approach and I
thought cool so I approached and spent
the next three weeks on the jury but it
got me to thinking that we too rarely
get to utter the really cool lines you
know the ones that you hear in the
movies how many of us get to say sponge
clamp sutures or three two one ignition
or I'd like to thank the academy or I
Barack Hussein Obama do solemnly
faithfully execute whatever count on a
harvard-educated Supreme Court justice
to screw up a 35 word oath of office
dude work dude or or up periscope now
how cool would it be to say up periscope
in my case it would probably be down
periscope after accidentally ramming
some Greenpeace research vessel and get
us the hell out of here but captain
Buckley what about the survivors screw
the survivors
this is my career we're talking about
when I fly home I call from the airport
and say the eagle has landed to which
the reply is usually great tell the
Eagle to pick up a quart of milk on the
way home so ladies and gentlemen go
forth and speak the cool lines yes you
can but whatever else life holds in
store for you and may it hold every
blessing and every happiness there's one
very cool line that you can already say
Yale 2009 it's whatever proof so as they
also say over at the development office
whose best friend forever you now
officially our boola boola god bless
have amazing lives knock'em dead and I
am out of here